I see now New Year's Eve planning is
underway in Rampart casinos helping with
their newest restaurant swedini Fiamma
so Chef Paula magash is here with the
festive details and the sizzling stove
okay we've been smelling this food the
entire show and I just can't wait to dig
in so first and foremost this is a new
restaurant just introduce us to it what
goes on there what kind of food are we
eating so we have uh Italian we're open
for dinner only uh seven days a week
exclusive we open at five o'clock and we
have a great wine list so it's about a
little over 25 bottles of wine under 30
like at 35 price point that's a there's
a wine program right absolutely that's
amazing 35 dollars
[Music]
and some seafood and traditional you
know approachable neighborhood items and
of course on top of the wine for New
Year's Eve we're having I assume some
champagne bubbly absolutely okay okay
now this is your inaugural New Year's
Eve dinner so what is going on what is
in store for everybody so we're doing a
couple dishes
um we have some swordfish we have some
drunken spaghetti so we like that here
we like that with a little pancetta um
today we're cooking some lamb chops with
some how did you know Chef Paula that is
my favorite it was I I just I got the
note I know I know we're just connecting
that way okay let's let's get let's
start tasting the lamb chops because I
have some made ones here I do yes
polenta polenta is like a warm Italian
hug okay so it's a little bit of
cornmeal we did it with a little bit of
heavy cream and some stock this is just
a little bit of the lamju so a little
bit the red wine in there absolutely
some braised
polenta the polenta and then the brace
fennel we have a little olive tapenade
to
try this with the that and then a little
bit of some most startup so it's like
it's so good yeah preserved with the
orange a little bit of mustard seeds a
little bit of fennel a little bay leaf
in there this presentation can you guys
see this plate this is beautiful oh my
gosh okay so while I go ahead and bite
into this yes juicy Lamb Chop um when
people come in for New Year's is it a
prefix menu is it can we order anything
we want how does it work uh you can
order pretty much anything you want so
what we're doing is we're doing some
features so we have some features the
lamb chops the swordfish we have the
drunken spaghetti as an appetizer but if
you want a pizza margarita the ovens are
on ready to go
um this is so good A little bit of
tiramisu we've got if you want some
steamed mussels we've got some steamed
mussels uh wash it down with a little
limoncello Martini we have a aperol
spritz
I'm like overwhelmed like oh my God I
just want it all um and how do people
make reservations for for New Year's and
Beyond so yeah can go through
rampartcasino.com otherwise you can do
open table as well and book it
so I'm sorry
continue to eat absolutely that's why we
brought some extra as well thank you so
much that's Paula and welcome to lots of